In this final lecture.
I wanted to briefly contrast the way
that classical and evolutionary medicine
look at issues.
Evolutionary insights are only helpful
some of the time it doesn't replace
earlier approaches.
Evolutionary medicine compliments
them by providing additional insights.
These insights are currently more
important for the clinical treatment of
infectious disease,
cancer and auto immune disease than
they are for many other conditions.
The two ways of looking at the world
and make different basic assumptions.
Evolutionary medicine looks at
patients not as machines who broke,
who's broken.
Parts can be replaced if broken and it
doesn't look at this at pathogens as
machines that can be disabled
by breaking their parts,
without having other consequences.
Both patients and pathogens are bundles
of tradeoffs in which it's impossible to
change one thing without
also changing something else
because evolution has already greatly
improved fitness in the face of trade offs
and constraints.
Changing those tradeoffs is often costly.
Yeah.
This doesn't mean we should not treat.
Of course we should treat,
but it does mean that we need heightened
awareness about the potential negative
consequences of treatment.
Another way of looking at the world that
is not part of classical medicine is
that of conflict and evolutionary
conflicts are involved in some diseases.
For example,
it is not been standard to think of
mother and fetus is in conflict over
maternal investment or if infant behavior
is modulated by conflict of maternal
and paternal interests.
Yeah,
evolutionary conflict theory has remodeled
or views of family health in very
fundamental ways.
Okay.
As we better understand the
mechanisms that mediate those effects,
we should be able to develop novel
treatments for diseases of pregnancy and
perhaps have some mental disorders.
We also gained great insight from mismatch
and here the important insights could
lead to novel treatments for
allergies, Asthma, autoimmune disease,
and also to use our understanding of
the changes that we've experienced in
modern environments to treat obesity,
type two diabetes and
cardiovascular disease.
So in conclusion,
it would be foolish to displace
fascinating and useful cell and molecular
science to make way for
evolutionary insights. Instead,
we need to connect the insights from
evolutionary biology to insights from
molecular and cell science to produce new
interdisciplinary research that yields
integrated knowledge that's reliable,
exciting, general, and useful.
It will reduce suffering
and it will save lives.